the live footage showed hooded armed men
storming this TV station in guak Kil and
taking the host and crew
hostage shots were heard on the set as
journalists beged not to be harmed
before the signal was cut off it was the
most Brazen attack in a day of chaos
across Ecuador gang members detonated
car bombs attacked universities and
kidnapped or killed policemen in seven
cities in a declaration of war against
the government of President Danielle
NOOA and his attempts at a security
Crackdown the 35-year-old president who
began his term less than two months ago
responded by declaring a state of
internal conflict a day after decreeing
a 60 days state of emergency and
nighttime curfew he named 22 gangs as
terrorist organizations and Military
targets
From This Moment every terrorist group
mentioned in the decree has become a
military Target the present and future
of our country is at play we will not
desist or
negotiate the crisis has escalated
following the escape from prison on
Sunday of adul masas better known as
fito Ecuador's most powerful drug lord
before he could be transferred to a
different prison the violence broke out
in the coastal city of guak Kil in
ismeralda but has extended to the
capital Kito and even to safe and
peaceful tourist locations like
quena all citizens are afraid today
there are attacks in Kito kka coedo
everywhere the police arrested 13 gunmen
who allegedly took over the television
station and freed the hostages but they
have been unable to stop the rest of the
mam neighboring Peru also declared an
emergency along its northern border in
recent years Ecuador has been living
through an unprecedented security crisis
fueled by drug trafficking that
authorities have failed to address
turning it into Latin America's most
dangerous
country we all know that when there
attempts to transfer powerful prisoners
violence occurs the question is why the
government is unable to take preventive
measures the escalation of violence was
a time bomb that has exploded in
president Noble's hands and so far no
has been able to break the link between
the prison gangs and the violence that
has brought Ecuador to unprecedented
levels of chaos and fear alexand Al
jazer
Kito make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer